rock en temps quand vous entendez des
gens qui ne soutiennent pas la
manifestation des policiers
écoutez ça me choque parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous étions quand même
trente cinq mille personnes mais non
rentrée 2011 comprend ça me tue n'était
pas inquiet avoue parler de tolérance
tout à l'heure ouais mais c'est
maintenant par leur art d'affaires
demande série en cours qui aurait bien
réussi aux citoyens qu europe et de
nombreux chasseurs connu au genou
de nombreux citoyens sont venus nous
soutenir parce que vous savez des
conditions d'exercice ultra difficile
d'autres métiers que savaient les
victimes de nantes de violence ce sont
les policiers on prend des pam et or les
pavés est ce qu'en pareilles à ceux qui
les prennent dans la gueule des pavés et
effectivement voilà donc qui a serré ce
cas là il peut aussi en parler tout à
fait donc y avait là dessus c'est très
bien qu'on soit venu parce que on a des
revendications fortes
il y avait des images fortes en vidéo
qui ont été montrées et il ya un état de
colère et d'agde exaspération profonde
je vous rappelle que la police est quand
même le dden le dernier rempart
républicains de l'autre institution
alors jean marie meyer vous étiez la
manifestation absolument je suis un ami
de la police
j'ai un côté de moi un mec qui est un
ami de vingt ans qu à risquer sa vie
pour la france
il est mon ami et moi c'est le jeudi est
aussi la travailler travailler que moi
donc je pense tout simplement coeur et
moi je globalement je sais pas quels
sont les guerres internes
oui au milieu de deux den1 police ce que
je sais moi simplement c'est que c'est
des mecs qui sont au service de la
nation
je suis à fond avec eux et je suis donc
résolument un ami de la police je trouve
insupportable qu'on puisse ou s'attaquer
à eux qu'ils se fassent caillassé qu'ils
se fassent ou assassinés ils sont au
front il gagne pas beaucoup d'argent et
donc c'est pas très populaire peut-être
d'être avec la police mais moi je suis
contre tout le monde avec la politique
n'ont aucun le crime mais non quelle est
la chose la mal aimée tu te contredis tu
te contredis c'est une porsche
non j'ai rien à gagner ici je suis un
ami de la police dit avec l'école jean
est pourquoi le dire non mais jean marie
bigard les attendait qu'il ya des façons
défend la police - par exemple chez moi
je défends la police dans moto près d'un
commissariat et pour votre maison mais
dans mon dos mamilla 1 500 commissariat
soit ouvert ce pub chez moi chez moi si
je me fais agresser ou là des après 17
heures
j'ai pas de commissariats pour aller
porter plainte parce que le commissariat
il est fermé et voyez donc je dois
quelque mouvement d'épaulé avec
l'extrême droite à l'heure actuelle
rappelle expliquez moi pourquoi tous les
parlementaires de gauche de droite du
parti communiste jadot étaient présents
et pourquoi les filles étaient pas
présents parce que peut-être qu'ils ont
un problème de compréhension des
principes républicains dans ce pays ces
gens là des problèmes de compréhension
c'était pas le moment là c'était pas le
mot marqué le jury dit que votre
problème c'était la justice mais la
police est constitué
nous apprenons que ça non mais vous
prenez la parole quand je vous la donne
isabelle morini bosc alors moi je suis
un peu surprise raquel parce que tu tout
ce que tu n'y va dans le sens de la
police étudie fallait pas y aller mais
en ce moment ils les flics ils sont là
pour protéger aurait d'autres passaient
leur temps à essayer de se protéger
donc et un vice de forme absolument
profond et là on en est intel stable
maintenant que oui je pense que
profondément et vous soutenir absolument
sans réserve sans réserve